Okay, Katie asked me to introduce to you Principle Component Analysis,
often called PCA.
PCA is one of these things that's been used thoroughly in all kinds of
data analysis including feature set compression.
And it's really good to get a basic understanding of what it is so
you can use it every time you want to visualize data.
Let me start with an example quiz.
You have a two dimensional data space.
And here's your data.
And for the time being,
I'm just going to use the single class, we can change this later.
Question asks you, sounds trivial, but
I want to know what is the dimensionality of the data.
And just give you two choices, either one dimensional or two dimensional.
If you look at that data what would you think?